good evening everyone welcome to this
extraordinary panel meeting thank you
members for coming along and thank you
to the officers uh fire alarm procedures
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices down the main
staircase opposite lifts in the foyer
assemble in Hawley Square on the green
and officers will assist you and advise
you when it's deemed to safe to return
to the chamber
with everyone present please ensure that
their mobile phones are turned to silent
they're not used to make or receive
calls whilst this meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
nope and we haven't got any members of
the public so we'll move on
[Applause]
uh speaking under 20.1 I've got the
following members who've asked to ask a
question this evening I've got
counseling manners on item eight and
Council of town in on item nine I have
not received any requests for public
speaking to move on to that uh item one
on the agenda apologies for absence uh
I've had councilor Wing being replaced
by councilor Garner and Council Cup
being placed by councilor white have got
any more apologies
apologies from councilor Pope
thank you Council going
okay any Declarations of Interest all
right
uh apologies from Council uh dabrow
replaced by councilor right
thank you
uh item number two are there any
Declarations of Interest
no no Declarations of Interest okay item
three uh first items on the agenda this
evening at the broadstairs flood and
Coast protection scheme I will now call
on Mr Humber to introduce the report
thank you chair
um okay so the broadstairs flood and
Coach protection scheme is funded via
the environment agency and local Levy
grant funding to the value of 880 000
pounds and that's in the 23 24 Capital
program
the pier at broadstairs was first
constructed 250 years ago and plays a
vital role in stabilizing the beach
and it's that beach at Viking Bay in
combination with the more recent
concrete sea walls that protects the
low-lying Residential Properties
directly behind the beach
if the coastal defense including the
pier were to fail in the next 20 years
54 homes are expected to be lost to
Coastal erosion and 95 homes in the next
100 years
the scheme will reduce flood risk that's
flooding by the sea to properties on
Harbor Street in broadstairs and also to
the rear of Viking Bay
with the effects of climate change
causing sea level rise and increased
intensity and regularity of storm events
the risk of doing nothing is that these
low-lying properties will experience
flooding more regularly
the jetty is an important Beach control
structure and if damaged or lost it
would have the effect of narrowing the
beach profile at Viking Bay leading to a
loss of amenity on the beach and and
also that more frequent flooding and
eventually Cliff erosion as well
the scheme includes Works to the facing
blocks of the pier the concrete blocks
that form the fabric of the pier repairs
to the fisherman's slipway repairs and
improvements to the Sea walls and
repairs to the Cobblestone steps to the
foreshore it also includes resurfacing
to the car park and installation of uh
Timber of Timber floodgates
this scheme will improve the standard of
flood defense from the current one in
10-year standard to a one in 200 year
standard so that is a one in 200 year
storm would be required to to cause
flooding after the works are completed
planning permission for the scheme was
granted in June and tender Dawkins
documents have been prepared ready for
competitive procurement the construction
phase is likely to be programmed from
April to June next year
thank you
so members have you any questions or
comments you'd like to make on that
report
oh no okay so we'll move on so we're
asked if there's no recommendations just
to note the report
and that's all noted thank you
okay moving on to item agenda agenda
item number four the Viking beta dumpton
Gap C Will Repair scheme
I now call on Mr Humber again it's all
about you tonight right all to introduce
the report
thank you chair uh so yeah this is
another Capital coach protection scheme
and it's immediately adjacent actually
to the uh to the to the process flood
and cash protection scheme so this is a
capital maintenance project between uh
Viking Bay and Dunton Gap
um it focuses on an 1100 meter length of
sea wall between preachers null at
Viking Bay and and just to the south of
of Dunton Gap
to see wall there is about 60 years old
and many of the structural components
um such as the concrete apron blocks and
wave return copings and the berm slabs
on the top the Promenade slabs have
become eroded by wave energy and tidal
action
following a successful application for
grant funding via the environment
agency's flood and Coastal erosion risk
management fund
a sum of 406 000 has been allocated to
this scheme
um
we're saying the council has 11 miles of
Seawall and such large-scale
refurbishment projects are important to
maintain the existing infrastructure
that we have around our Coastline
without undertaking works of that nature
we'd be in a position where sort of our
sea walls and popular Coastal promenades
would in time need to be closed to the
public on health and safety grounds and
sort of the damage to those walls from
from storms and the loss of the fill
material will be detrimental to our
internationally designated coastline
thank you chair
thank you again members have you got any
questions or comments you'd like to make
councilor Greene
just to say and I'm really pleased that
timely work like this is being done
and you know we're not waiting for
uh catastrophe to happen
but I was today
walking along Ramsgate East Pier
and that seems to be have suffered
some quite significant damage recently
and I wondered if there are any plans to
look at that or
um or what the officer felt
okay uh yeah thank you councilor green
so the East period Ramsgate is inspected
by the maintenance team at the Portland
Harbor
um I don't know specifically the damage
that you're referring to but it's
certainly something I'll I'll inquire
about and look into and clearly that's a
you know an important uh structure for
the for the harbor and it's also a grade
two style listed structure so it's
important that we maintain we maintain
that
Castle point
[Music]
to these reports
um really clear and useful as always
um
I guess my first question covers
probably covers both item agenda items
and it's really around the the program
of works is there going to be a
published full scheme of how this work
is being carried out just thinking from
the point of view of any businesses that
might be affected by the construction
work in the area
um yes when the program is confirmed
there will be engagement with um local
businesses and we normally do a
um you know a statement a media
statement about the works going on
um the timing of these sort of works is
is is is always very sensitive we have
to avoid the overwintering period
largely because of the effect that will
have on overwintering birds that are
nationally and internationally
designated in some cases
um so yeah and obviously the summer
period is very important for um you know
local businesses and the you know the
immunity value of the Promenade so it's
quite difficult programming things but
uh in all cases there's consultation
with anyone who will be you know who who
may be affected by those works and
historically from experience of doing
these sort of schemes
um every effort is made by through
programming to minimize the impact on on
local business to make sure that we you
know we we complete the works that we
need to with with good consultation and
minimal impact
thank you have a have another question
um around so
about three months ago on the cliff top
in broadstairs just by where Eagle house
is there was a really severe sinkhole I
guess it was about
15 foot deep 20 foot deep
um now obviously I'm not sure what
caused that but has there been a full
survey or will there be a full survey
carried out across this this entire
patch just to make sure that there is
you know we have mitigation in place for
any further sinkholes or is it
structurally sound or is that is there
going to be long-term problems with the
integrity
okay all right so I'm I'm aware of that
uh failure that occurred on the
Promenade at uh broadstairs and
that's a a fairly unusual situation in
that there was a a lot of film material
behind a uh a concrete wall or a wall
which is by by eagle house and it was
very likely caused by um groundwater you
know moving and
um washing the fine material out behind
there and gradually causing a hole to a
hole to occur
um generally that's not the case around
around the rest of the coastline in the
where there's exposed chalk Cliffs it's
more predictable in terms of what what
happens with the with the Promenade
um it's worth saying that the technical
services team undertake routine annual
inspections around the entire Coastline
so that's the promenades the upper
promos lower promenades um you know
groin steps see what you know sea walls
everything is is inspected ham railings
and what have you there's also a program
of repair Works to Cliff facing
structures so precisely the sort of
structure that uh that we were talking
about in this instance where the where
the hole occurred behind it but there is
you know is
um uh sort of proactive preventative
inspection work going on around the
around the coastline on a routine basis
Council them all
yes thank you chair and thank you Mike
for your presentations the only reason
I'm bringing this up now is because of
the comments that councilor Bryce has
made regarding the sinkhole
um so you also probably are aware that
we have quite a large heavy good
vehicles driving and reversing up and
down that seafront area
um to the extent that a CCTV camera was
knocked over
and disappeared in your care or tdc's
care never to be replaced and we're
wondering why that's not being replaced
every time we ask we're given an excuse
that it's now UK power Network they
can't get power to it but the CCT camera
CCTV cameras were quite important for
checking and monitoring the antisocial
behavior that was happening at that
particular time and the barrier where
these vehicles gain entry I believe one
of the companies that was renting for
filming or renting to use the green
Victoria Gardens they damaged it I
believe it's been repaired now but if we
don't have these monitored and these
areas protected and preventing these
vehicles from doing what they're doing
as there's no reason for them to drive
up the Promenade they can reverse up
past the Public House Dickens and their
bin men can walk the bins up to their
trucks is because they don't want to and
we just need to be mindful that this is
something that ball says is suffering
all the time and we are raising it
through the the channels to TDC but it
doesn't seem to be
being resolved in a speedier manner
which is sometimes a bit frustrating for
the local councilors so I just thought
I'd bring that to your attention as well
thank you I think we've got a bit off
peace there with this report but okay
um so I I am aware that the CCTV camera
was in October it was probably two years
ago or something like that now
um I will have to find out what the
latest position is with replacing it or
whether the plan is still to replace it
but perhaps I can get you know an
officer to contact you about that and
update you if that's okay
thank you can I just congratulate
officers on bringing in the environment
agency funding but ask about the process
for that is that the competitive uh
funding so if we've got this money so
Dover hasn't or whatever is that how it
works
um I suppose in a manner of speaking yes
so the the funding criteria is is sort
of outcome measure
based so we need to prove through
um sort of a technical report through a
study
what the level of risk currently is and
the number of properties being protected
um so yeah the outcome measures are a
function of those of those things
um there is yeah there are more
applications than there are than there
is funding so the funding is
um from defra but the environment agency
have a strategic overview so they
actually administer the fund and um
yeah I mean yeah there are certainly
more schemes there's a red line if you
like beyond beyond which um schemes
wouldn't wouldn't receive funding so yes
it is competitive yeah
yeah I'll make sure this is my last
question I've kind of dominated this one
so apologies
um
I was just going to ask you about the
projected lifespan of the work we're
doing because obviously
if this was built 100 or so years ago
the world has changed and the probably
the pressures that any works are gonna
under come under over the next 100 years
are going to be a you know a step change
probably worse let's be honest than than
has been for the previous hundred years
um are we are we changing the design or
the materials that we're using is there
uh is this future-proof basically what
I'm asking
uh yeah I mean good good question the uh
obviously seawalls have an incredibly
hard life they have to uh you know
resist the the forces of of wave energy
and freeze Thor and all those things
over a very long period of time
um all the design work that we do now
and for some time uh probably for the
last 20 odd years that we've been doing
it always takes into account the effects
of climate change so the UK climate
change project projections are updated
over time and we always work to the
latest standards and the
um the requirement is for the sea wall
to be able to perform at the end of its
design life based on what what the um
what the sea level rise and the you know
if you like the increased storminess the
increasing intensity of the storm will
be at that point
we designed for a hundred year life
generally speaking for a seawall
um with the acceptance that it will
require periods of major maintenance
during that time but it's normally the
economics are normally based on a
hundred year life
um so if you like this scheme
um is designed or the broadstairs flood
and case protection scheme is designed
um sort of 100 years
um you know forward and the and the
um see level at that time so that's what
that's the that's the you know the level
of design that uh that's considered
okay remember there's any further
questions
Council Davis
um I'd just like to uh
record how pleased I am that this works
being done because the protection of the
coastline is absolutely vital and we do
have a particularly the plethora of
protections on them without going off
peace is the this is the broadstairs
protection scheme just while we're here
Mike if I could ask Ramsgate Western
Undercliff the the wooden firms the yes
the break waters are in horrendous
condition and all the rest of it is
there any plan to to
refurbish or support those because they
do stop Longshore drift obviously
um yes it's true yeah so those were
obviously originally put there to stop
Longshore drift before the port was
built so the port has largely superseded
the requirement for those those groins
although they do hold a bit of material
in the in the corner yeah um
the yeah the the plan with those because
we have to uh plan for the limited
amount of resources we've got is to
maintain keep them safe but not
necessarily them yeah so yeah so make
sure they're safe that they're not you
know they're not a danger to the public
no I can see the logic in that because
of course we have views on the port and
it's impact on the title anyway in other
areas yeah okay okay thanks but for the
record excellent scheme and it's vital
we protect our coastlines thank you
okay so do we wish to make any
recommendations before we send this
report off to cabinet
no okay so if we all know the report
please thank you okay moving on to item
five the LED Street lighting contract
again I call our Mr Humber
thank you thank you chair uh so this is
a capital
um scheme in the 2324 program the
council is responsible for about 500
street lights around the district this
project will result in improvements to
approximately 200 of those with Works
including either a new LED lamp or an
LED brand new entire LED fitting or a
new column
through stakeholder engagement with
broadstairs Town Council the
contribution has been secured to
undertake works at Victoria Parade and
on broadstairs Harbor including festoon
lights which will all be led
um
tender documents for the for this work
have been have been prepared and the
Planned time scale for this is for it to
start in January next year and be
completed by July next year the light
the lighting improvements are right
across the district so it's not all in
one place it's there's um there's
various lights based on inspection and
um and need
right across the district
thank you
thank you members any questions
councilor Garner
thank you yeah thank you Mike um we
those of us who are on board stairs Town
Council as well as TDC Council have sat
down with you to discuss this uh
recently
um specifically around
um
the contribution from board citizens and
Peter's Town Town Council so I know I'm
here as a TDC counselor but I will
mention a concern maybe that we have or
I have as a without wanting to speak for
anybody else as a as a Town Council
about the 50 000 so you mentioned that
obviously this project covers lighting
across
the district yes um there is obviously
there is a focus on the the board with
some of the Victoria Gardens area I mean
our concern or my concern sorry could be
that we've we the Town Council and I
believe approved a contribution of up to
000 pound so
I would like to ensure that if the this
money was was used if needed for the Vic
for the broadstairs related elements and
not to be you not used say if um to
cover the costs of lighting upgrades in
other parts of thanet because there's a
budget there already so if when we see a
more I assume there will be a more
detailed breakdown of the costings and
if
we are able to achieve delivery of this
project at less than the um
the total
budget which is the 2885 Plus
50k then the bit that won't be spent
will be part of the Town council's 50k
rather than that being the first bit
that's spent if you see what I mean
thank you
um yeah yeah thank you counselor
um to clarify the uh the contribution I
think is for is for enhanced lighting so
for student lighting and enhanced
lighting that if we were just doing the
the work to provide
um immunity lighting we wouldn't we
wouldn't do that work so I think the
contribution is to for a higher
specification of lighting it well it
certainly won't be spent elsewhere the
money from broadstairs Town Council will
be spent on Victoria Parade and at the
harbor which I think is where that
um
higher higher specification for student
lighting will be will be installed so
yeah absolutely it will only be spent on
on the investment of broadstairs
yeah
yeah okay thank you for that and this is
coming back to Cabinet isn't it to
on Thursday okay so all right thank you
uh Council bye
thanks again to Echo uh councilor
Garner's um words this is a good report
and obviously we're as as with our
broadstairs hat on we're really happy
that this is happening
um obviously in your report you say the
work is going to happen between January
and July
um
is there a is there a prioritization of
area so obviously this is covering
broadstairs Harbor you know by the time
it gets to Easter we're we're well into
you know we start to get visitors to the
area it would be amazing to have
everything in place as far as possible
ready for the time that we we get
visitors coming into the area so is
there a is there a plan in place to make
sure that we're we're maximizing and I
guess it's the same for for Ramsgate
Central Ramsgate and and areas in
Margate as well
um yeah yeah the simple answer is is yes
um every you know best Endeavors we made
to program such that it doesn't impact
you know the so that we're doing the
sort of quieter areas later on in the
season I mean just a note as well of
course this will need to work around or
work with the process flooding cash
protection scheme which is also uh
programmed for next year so we can't
have two things going on on top of each
other but yeah that sort of needs to be
a bit of careful programming but uh but
yeah again minimizing impact is
important so yeah yeah Endeavors we made
for them thank you
Council Austin
um
[Music]
quick and simple question which is quite
good coming from me I think
um when KCC have replaced a substantial
number of the street lights for instance
of quote Spencer Square uh they claimed
and and this relates to the location and
the Heritage aspects particularly with
the parks and things that we're talking
about here
um there were some very disappointing
decisions taken there and what they did
was ripped out Heritage posts and
columns rather than just replacing the
top of the with the unit and said they
weren't compatible now there are
Heritage style things can I just confirm
that we're not going to do what's
happened around me where you know we've
suddenly got
a a metal industrial looking pole that's
completely incongruous with the area are
we going to sort of obviously uh look I
know it's more expensive but will we
probably be preserving that
yes so the majority of the work is Ellie
is new lights on top of the pole rather
than the pole there are some columns
that need to be replaced where those are
in a conservation area or there's a you
know there's a conservation need then
those would be replaced with the SIM
with a similar similar type I it's
probably something I need to confirm to
you because I haven't got all the detail
of
where others need to be replaced and
what the type that they'll be replaced
with so I think it's something that I
can I can come back on or I can get an
officer to come to come back on yeah
yeah no no so if it's a it's a fair
point yeah yeah yeah but it's obviously
you know I I didn't highlight it a
little bit you know another key driver
for this project is you know it it fits
with the um you know with the Net Zero
um uh you know strategy and LED lighting
has a much lower maintenance footprint
we it will last a lot longer without
having you know people having to go and
replace bulbs and climb up columns and
that sort of thing so it fits with all
those things as well
Council Austin
thank you chair
um I I was going to say um well done on
the LED lighting Etc I was also going to
ask a similar question to cancer Davis
which is about where you do have to
replace a column making sure that it's
appropriate Etc I think at one stage
used to be a point you could stand in
Ramsgate whereas you looked around you
could see seven different styles of
lighting columns we we don't want that
we don't want that we it's got to be uh
it's got to be coherent with the with
the surroundings and and I'm pleased to
note that and if you are sharing
information on that it would be great if
you could share it with all of us thank
you
yeah and I totally agree and I will you
know
um get more detail and share that yeah
okay councilor butcher
uh thank you chair and
uh hi Mike um I just wanted to ask
there's two you said there were 200
um street lights being upgraded and
because I started whereabouts in thanet
will those be because obviously some in
broadstairs but
where will the others be thank you
uh yes I mean so they are spread uh
around so the list I've got a table in
front of me so it's broadstairs Clifton
birchington cliftonville Dane Valley
Ramsgate Kingsgate margates and Nicholas
Minster akol and Westgate
um I can provide a table with where how
many in each but it's it's across the
district
um that uh that the works go on so we we
have a um a schedule and an inspection
regime for those 500 lights across so
this this is based on the most urgent
need that these you know these are these
works are being done
so happy to happy to share a bit more
detail on that
no uh thank you okay
could I ask does this scheme include the
sturgeon lights
the sturgeon lights in uh Margaret or
Ramsgate or both uh as far as I'm aware
it doesn't no
um but again it's it's detail I can I
can check on
okay any more questions members
no okay we're asked to before we send it
off together to make any recommendations
or the recommendations we wish to make
nope okay so we asked to note the report
then okay moving on to item number six
the coastal zone maintenance contract
and again Mr Humber
thank you chair
um so this is yeah the coastal zone
maintenance contract we have 16 miles of
Coastline uh around the district that's
maintained
um by uh by the technical services team
and that includes 11 miles of Seawall
upper Promenade railings steps Bridges
groins slipways all those sort of assets
um they're maintained through a
maintenance Pro a maintenance contract
with a you know with a five-year
contract with the contractor that a
civil engineering contractor which is
due to expire in January 24.
um this is about putting in place a new
contract to continue that work is
proposed to put in place a three-year
contract with a two-year extension
option which is actually the same as the
the one that we have now which is going
to expire shortly
um this is base budget funded Revenue
maintenance work it's informed by
regular detailed inspections of the
Coastline by the technical services Team
without this contract would be unable to
react to Urgent and routine repair work
to ensure that we get the maximum
working life out of our Coastal
infrastructure we would also without
this sort of contract be open to an
increased level of Insurance liability
because of the condition of the asset
we're gradually deteriorate
the budget value for this each year is
244 000 pounds but there are occasions
when there's an advantage to deliver
other work other maintenance work via
this contract so approximately three
hundred thousand pound per annum is
spent on this giving the contractor
value of 1.5 million over those full
five years thank you
thank you Mike members any questions
can't slip by
so when the current contractors have
delivered their work do we have a a
review process with them do they come
back and
um and when is that conducted
uh yeah so it's worth saying that there
are several hundred Works orders placed
every year on this contract and the
technical services team administer that
so
um some of it is from those inspections
some of it's uh from reports from the
member of the public or or observations
made on site that it could be anything
from a piece of broken railing to you
know surfacing repair trip hazards and
the the team put out those Works orders
they administer the work they supervise
not everything but a proportion of the
work and then inspect the work before
it's paid for so there's a there's a a
regime to to running through that
process and completing the work so we
have a degree of confidence that that
the work is is coming in at a standard
that we require yes yeah I mean yes it's
inspected and anything that doesn't meet
the requirements I mean there is a
specification in the contract there are
drawings to say you know standard
details of of repairs and things if they
don't meet those standards then the
contractor will be required to to
rectify those defects by whatever means
would be agreed with the engineer and is
this going out to multiple contractors
no so this isn't so we many years ago we
had a schedule of rates uh process with
many contractors on a list that you
could call off
um for the last uh certainly 10 years
we've had a single contractor win a you
know win the project win the the
contract for a set period of time so
it's competitively tendered and they
they yeah they win it so it is a single
term maintenance contractor who
um carries out the works based on a
schedule in the in the contract but that
was my question so it's going out to
it's going out to Tender then oh yes so
this is competitively yeah competitively
tender yeah okay yeah
okay any further questions members uh
Council Lawson I just clarified to open
tender so anybody appropriately
qualified could apply there isn't there
isn't any kind of a call off list or
anything like that anymore
uh no yeah so this is open tender
because of the the value of it um you
know this this triggers the full
requirements of the public contract
regulations and um and yes it's open
Tinder yeah yeah
cancel the point and when it comes to
making that decision to select the the
contractor is this coming back to
overview and scrutiny or
cabinet
[Music]
so who makes that decision basically
yeah so um yeah the the um the Monday's
in the budget and the uh cabinet
decision will
um uh will give up you know officers the
authority to award that contract
um the contract itself has uh sort of
quality and price criteria in it and the
you know it's a competitive contract so
there's an evaluation process once the
winning contractor is identified a
contract will be awarded by by officers
through um through the legal service
um so there won't be another member
decision on that
okay members we're asked to make any
recommendations
no no recommendations so ask to note the
report please okay
you can have a break now Mike
I'm moving on to item number seven the
new contracts for the supply of
electricity to 264 sites within the TDC
portfolio so I call on Mr surname thank
you chair
um this report invites members of the
overview and scrutiny panel to review
the cabinet report for the council to
enter into a new contract for the supply
of electricity to 264 sites within tdc's
portfolio
the council is required to ensure best
value for money when procuring its
contracts and as such the council is
required to reprocure its electricity
Supply contract before the renewal date
which is the 1st of October
he's coming to this meeting obviously
because it's in excess of 750 000.
um
the council's current electricity Supply
contract comes to an end at the end of
September and requires reprocuring we've
been through the appropriate process use
laser to Tender the contract and have
identified A supplier there's an anomaly
with this one in that in previous years
due to the price of electricity it
wasn't actually deemed a key decision we
could have let the contract it wouldn't
have come through this process but
because of the ongoing increases and the
instability within the utilities Market
it's effectively ended up in excess of
the 750 000. so it's effectively brought
here for you for you to review in order
to make any recommendations if you so
wish before it goes to cabinet thank you
thank you members
I've got Council Austin and councilor
Davis
thank you chair I just wanted to ask um
why it's coming to cabinet so late
before the the end of the contract is
that to do with the way that the process
works and the cost of the electricity or
whatever it feels like a bit of a
brinkmanship sort of way of going about
it but presumably there is a Russian
Alpha
it's exactly what I said it's unusual in
the context of in previous years but for
the whole time I've been this I've been
here 25 years we've never had to bring
it as a key decision so it was we were
late to finding out that that it was in
excess it was going to be in excess of
750 and therefore in excess of a key
decision
I'd like to thank councilor Austin for
asking exactly the right questions
are gone
yeah thank you I just wanted to check
the two these 264 sites
are they all
TDC
estate offices housing I mean enough
there are no properties that we let out
I can't say whether any of them are let
if they're let then the cost is passed
on these are 264 of the main sites that
the council operates and that does
include the housing estate as part of
that there may be properties within
there that will run our industrial state
so that therefore have a power supply if
they're empty or whatever in terms of
standing charges I could check if you
want me to to see if any of the
properties are left but it'll be minimal
no I said I mean you've said if they are
lit then the costs will be passed on so
a minimal portion of this will be
recouped through the events that we
charge out essentially
any further questions about this
okay so I presume there's no
recommendations so uh we'll send this
off to cabinet uh moving on item eight
the department for leveling up housing
and communities funding updates
simplification Pathfinder
I do have councilor managers wanted to
speak under 20.1 I think if it's a
question I think I'll let Miss Askew do
a presentation so we don't sort of ruin
that so and then you can ask your
question afterwards okay mrski
thank you so I've we've bought this
paper on the basis that it's going to
the next cabinet meeting and is the key
decision obviously it impacts on a
number of wards in terms of the process
and so the council's been lobbying
central government in order to simplify
the process around the key the three
capital programs that we've been awarded
the future High Street fund Town deal
and the leveling up fund projects and we
have been successfully awarded over 50
million pounds of capital funding for
the pro for projects across Ramsgate and
Margate and most of these programs are
were covered within the presentation
that I provided to this meeting on the
20th of July by way of an update
um on the basis of this being included
within the pilot suggests that we are
also one of the more successful local
authorities in this country in terms of
the funding that has been awarded we're
one of 10 local authorities to be part
of the
um
uh I was trying to think of the word the
the simplification Pathfinder pilot we
are going to have to find a an easier
um term for it
um two of which are in the Southeast
um and I know that Lewis has had about
the same amount of funding across the
the different programs that we've had
it's important to note that this pilot
is about governance and managing
reporting back to central government
rather than starting again in terms of
deciding where the funding should be
spent the projects have already been
agreed and through
um been through the formal government
approvals and our own processes that are
being included within this pilot program
and so there are a number of key
elements outlined in the report
there will be one single allocation
across the portfolio so we have a grant
statement that says government have
given us this amount of money and that
means that we will have XYZ remaining
for the rest of the program however on a
project by project basis we have
individual budget sheets and they will
remain in place and we will be checking
projects against those
um
there will be alongside that there's a
single set of outcomes and outputs
um across the whole of the portfolio so
in Annex one of the um cabinet report
um we've profiled each of the projects
across the new intervention themes
um around connectivity
unlocking Industrial and Commercial
development strengthening the visitor
and local service economy improving
quality of life for residents and
employment and education and then within
those are a set
within those are a set of
indicators which essentially match those
that were in the town deal and leveling
up fund programs with slight changes so
we've just mapped those across they will
be what we report back to central
government but again on a project by
project basis we still have those
targets that we initially put forward
within those projects so we will be
reporting on those internally and to
amalgamate them up to central government
um I think I said uh the presentation at
the last meeting we had three different
reporting mechanisms on the three
different programs which took up an
awful lot of Officer time we will now be
reporting once three monthly red Amber
green focusing on spend and progress and
then one six monthly more robust Report
with more narrative around projects
um delivery
um
improvements to the change in in
management will mean that we're not
queuing uh for eight to twelve weeks for
approvals on changes to any of the
projects we did have one in for the
future High Street fund and it took it
did take nearly 12 weeks and we were
advised that there had been 50 of the
programs had gone back for a project
adjustment so it's a way of central
government Trying to minimize that
burden on both the local Authority and
um
and central government so any changes
over five million pounds within the
program go back to central government
for approval but underneath that they
are approved through the local Authority
as the countable body and a commitment
has been made that those changes will be
made through a cabinet decision
and then lastly there'll be one main
contact so we have a Town's fund contact
we have a future High Street fund
contact and we have a leveling up
contact and then we have a cities and
local growth contact those will be
Amalgamated which means we have much
clearer reporting and support from
central government and our cities and
local growth contacts have been really
useful in helping us through this
program and and the development of The
Wider programs
um so central government requires the
council as the accountable body for this
funding to establish a Consolidated
governance structure which will be a
strategic oversight board the cabinet
report includes the proposal to create a
new oversight board to cover the pilot
projects we are required to have a set
certain people on the board including
all levels of government so County
district and town councils where we have
them the MPS and so we will have both of
our MPS invited to participate on the
board and then businesses and or
investors and representatives from the
community it's not a decision-making
board but they will support the council
in terms of reviewing delivery budgets
time scales risk and that monitoring and
evaluation process
um we welcome this engagement with
department for leveling up housing and
communities having improved contact as I
said with the department will make it
much easier to engage across the whole
of government and we've had an awful lot
of support so far we also welcome the
fact that through our engagement with
the department they have concluded that
than it District Council can be part of
this pilot our understanding is the
outputs from this will be used to inform
the department on how they engage with
local authorities in the future on these
Capital programs in order to understand
how they can better deploy and manage
the funding thank you
thank you okay members I've come to
councilor manners first before we'll
open it up to
panel
thank you chair thank you Louise
um
what will the process be for us as
individual Ward councilors to find out
and scrutinize the delivery of projects
within our respective wards
how frequently will we be updated and
how is this solely with regard to the
quarterly and six monthly reporting that
you mentioned or will that will there be
other opportunities and how will that
work exactly please
um I'm also concerned in the light of
cost inflation that money may be moved
from one project to another to
facilitate delivery
how will the community be involved in
that process will will they have a say
in how money is taken from one project
to move into the other and again what
would that process be please thank you
foreign
so as you know we recently held a public
event in Ramsgate for the Ramsgate
leveling up fund projects
um we are planning future ones
um which will allow not only Ward
councilors but
um the broader communities to come
together and understand where we are in
terms of the delivery of the projects
and to be able to feedback on the Reba
stages as we work through those
um we will obviously be bringing all of
the procurement contracts to Cabinet as
you've heard this evening we've had a
number of those already and some of
those are scheduled scheduled in for
this financial year so that will come
through the overview and scrutiny and
then through to Cabinet as well in terms
of that approval process we are where
there are specific things where local
communities can be involved we are
working through those particularly if
they're around things like job
opportunities or delivering specific
Services out of them for our communities
so there'll be some work around that
um we are always updating the website we
are always providing information into
the loop and Colin Carmichael's
fortnightly email that comes out to
members so we you know we're constantly
trying to keep members updated in those
ways but if there's anything specific
for a ward counselor then they will be
invited through the normal process
um
for uh finding out and then in terms of
moving money in terms of cost inflation
so at the moment all the projects as
outlined in the cabinet report will be
going forward as they are we
um as I I think I um mentioned at the
the previous meeting we are working on
each of those to understand that
inflationary and cost pressures and
where we can looking at
um value engineering private sector
funding or other Public Funding so we
have now submitted our stage one
application for the clock house and
should hear later on in this year and
we've also submitted our expression of
interest to the lottery fund for the
theater Royal and working with Arts
Council so it's on a project by project
basis that we're looking at the moment
in terms of future movement of money as
I said any of those decisions will come
back to cabinet
okay members I've got Council Austin
indicating and councilor green and
councilor Curry councilor Davis
thank you chair first of all huge
congratulations on being selected for
this pilot that sounds really really
good news as somebody who ran a national
charity with innumerable different
government contracts I I know how
incredibly time consuming it is the
different reporting schedule so having
this all coherent is going to free up a
lot of office of time and hopefully
reduce the amount of stress on your
cells and and uh and help things run
much more efficiently
um the red Amber green thing looks
excellent and is precisely the thing the
sort of thing that we have talked about
for scrutiny the kind of reporting that
we were asking for not for you or
colleagues to turn up every time Louise
um and and and give us a a detailed
report but that sort of very simple like
we get from house from our tenderness
service for example that that sort of
have we met this have we drawn down that
if we haven't why not what's the problem
and we felt that as a scrutiny panel and
a number of us felt that that was a
really important part of our role in
view of the enormous uh size and impact
of the of the various projects so
um so we'd be delighted to be able to
share through
um this panel in in that process as as
things go through to cabinet that would
be extremely helpful to us to to uh to
help with our monitoring and surgery
function
um I've got a couple of questions the
first one was about the governance
structure the the overseeing whatever
and how
members of the public how businesses and
so on would get involved in that
and then the second one was probably
rather more Ramsgate specific or I'm
sure it has generic applications which
is about where there might be
possibilities of finessing things so
that they fit together better I'm my
example would be the um the future High
streets
um money for the Road by the harbor and
the and the clock house and the Town
Square and all of that and the
suggestions that we've made about ways
that those could be made more coherent
and we could get better value out of it
but I'm sure there are examples
elsewhere as well and how much
flexibility you think you're going to
have as far as as far as those kinds of
things are concerned
thank you uh yeah we are hoping that it
will reduce admin and we can spend more
time working on the projects
um so the governance Arrangements one of
the things that we because it isn't a
decision-making board
um often people don't necessarily want
to get so involved because the kind of
the juicy bit has been done
um we also are mindful that it we don't
want it to be too large so that those
discussions are harder to have so
because there are a number of
organizations as well that have to be on
it so we send out we'll send out an
invite to each of those
um County and town councils and stroke
Charter trustees to set to to put
forward a representative to be on that
we are also then looking at
organizations so businesses and or
Community groups that have an
understanding of managing large sums of
money so that they understand about out
budgeting risk delivery mechanisms and
time scales so that they can easily then
participate in the discussion around
managing this funding
so the next step will be after cabinet
approvals is to then work through and
look at each of those organizations that
could be on it and and send out various
invites on on that basis we we are
looking at whether it's done it wide
businesses or if it's for example one
business from each of the towns because
we want to make sure that it's an easy
discussion and not a very Town focused
discussion
um so yeah that will be the process oh
sorry and the finessing and so the two
Highway schemes are now going to be
brought together so we will send it out
as a single contract
um
uh it makes much more sense and there is
an opportunity within that to finesse
what that might look like and how we can
make that work so yeah we're we're
really pleased about that
yes potentially yeah and we will look at
those
thank you
counselor green
yeah I too welcome the simplification
anything that cuts down on the
administrative burden is a good thing
so well done for that
um
I must admit I would feel more
comfortable if there were two boards one
for each town
um
I think I heard you just say you didn't
want it to be Town centered but these
bids are Town centered inevitably
have you considered having two boards
rather than one
um we haven't on the basis that we are
following the guidance that says to have
one a Consolidated
um governance Arrangement so in some of
the other areas they may well have two
Town deals
um because some of the
um other local Authority on sorry other
local authorities are metropolitan areas
so they may well have two downtown deal
boards already so the point is about
consolidating having a very focused
board
um you know there there may well be some
support for decision makings but the
local Authority is the accountable body
so it will be making those decisions on
that town if there are changes as
Council Austin suggested of some
finessing of some of the projects
um the board is about testing the
governance Arrangements making sure that
from a high level you know is is
delivery on time if it's not why not so
it although the projects are specific to
the town actually those delivery
mechanisms should be at a strategic
level and it is a strategic oversight
board if we had two one for Margate and
Ramsgate it doesn't actually reduce much
of the admin burden on the council in
terms of managing those and it makes
more sense to have one set of reporting
um to one board but we want to make sure
that we have representatives and they'll
also be learning across representatives
from the different towns as well and we
felt that was important
Council
thank you for your report Louise um I
did read all of it earlier on and I did
make some observations so this isn't so
much a question but some observations I
did I made I do think that this new
Arrangement is a positive step
certainly should make the administration
of the three schemes more
straightforward with less red tape going
forward all the projects have been
identified and it makes sense that any
decisions about redistributing funding
are made by those actually working on
these projects and have full access to
costing and timelines of course I'd like
to see every project take shape however
any match funding organization who for
whatever reason is unable to deliver
their projects should contact the new
Pathfinder board and be honest about
their situation so other arrangements
can be made and any further delays to
the management of these projects are
avoided these leveling up projects are
in place for the good of our communities
and should not be used as a means to
criticize officers and members who are
doing their best to deliver and support
them but sometimes do not have the right
to reply
thank you
did you want to come back on that thank
you I don't know if there's a question
there or just a comment sir
move on Council Davis
thanks yeah
um
again Louise I think this is really
welcome news because when we last met at
this committee I asked the question on
behalf of many people about why we
weren't further forward you explained
very small Department under resourced
and perhaps we're getting a better
understanding of the administrative
burden which is perhaps taking Focus off
of delivery If we're honest and I'm not
trying to be yeah
um I welcome also the flexibility that
is appearing because our original
understanding was that there was a
degree of flexibility within the
projects as they scoped out then we were
told that everything is ring fenced this
puts that flexibility back into it I've
got a couple of requests if you like
um particularly with regard to specific
projects because
always saying for example and we know
there's an issue with the smack voice
home project and The Bijou Hotel
whatever we're calling it this week
that building however and it's now grade
two style listed of course which has
been upgraded
can we have an assurance that if funds
are reallocated away from that to help
deliver something else which you know
may well have to happen that the fabric
of that building that can be written in
and that project is set in stone because
it is an integral part of the the
structure there so whilst that may have
to evolve can we please protect the
fabric whatever it's ultimate use
um
with regards to the board
as I say I think it's an excellent idea
because it starts to work to the kiss
principle of keeping the keep it simple
yeah
um
however
is it intended because it provides a
degree of scrutiny which this panel are
already with a program to provide can
you confirm it is in no way intended
Supply supplements rather than supplants
our role in ensuring transparency and
and scrutiny of the decisions as they go
along because we tonight we're live
streamed we're public and this is in the
public domain this board will meet
behind closed doors and therefore isn't
subject to the same degree of scrutiny
therefore it must surely come under our
scrutiny will you still be reporting to
us or will the steering committee be
reporting to us how will that be framed
um
of the reallocation of funding around
the smack boys
um
each of the projects have a set of
outputs and outcomes that have to be
delivered as part of the programs those
don't change we have
um confirmed central government that we
will deliver those
um when we were awarded the funding so
the out the if funding is reallocated
outputs and outcomes still have to be
delivered so what we can't do for
example with the smack boys is say spend
money on the outside of the building and
deliver no outputs and outcomes as far
as central government is concerned so we
are still though looking at the
opportunities for that building we are
working very closely with our property
team and the harbor team to think about
the future uses of that building and how
we make sure that it's Safeguard because
um it you know it's a beautiful building
and it's fundamental to the harbor
structures and um you know that's
incredibly important so there's a brick
in the wall isn't it it is so we are all
working together to consider what what
the opportunities for the future of that
building are if it isn't
um a restaurant with rooms an
entertainment space which is which has
proved to be challenging as I as I
mentioned last time and in terms of the
board and the role of a view and
scrutiny panel so
the council Remains the accountable body
cabinet is the decision maker and as I
said the report outlines that any
decisions that need to be made in terms
of changes within the projects will come
to cabinet and they are likely to be key
decisions and so they will come through
this this process and all of the
Contracting arrangements for
construction will be over the threshold
so they will again go to cabinet and
come through this overview and scrutiny
process so this is about having external
review of the processes that we are
going through in terms of governance it
doesn't replace a local Authority
accountable body governance of those
arrangements
so so we can be comfortable that we will
still get the same degree or more of
feedback will it come from that from
that but should we expect to be updated
by that committee though or will it
still be from yourselves as head of
regeneration and yeah you don't get rid
of me that easily it wasn't trying to
yeah so there is no change to our
current sort of screw to the
arrangements or nothing proposed there
no
um I do have a couple of other questions
Sheriff it's okay to continue
um
which uh also with regards to I think
you've explained how the members of will
be identified because effectively this
this panel will have those that are in
in place by definition of their role out
external to the panel and there are
those that are then obviously recruited
and invited
how will they be selected will that will
the sort of if you like the statutory
element of the panel
discuss that or will it be down to an
individual or just chairs discretion or
is there an open process on that so that
uh we're discussing that with cabinet at
the moment in terms of what's the best
way so essentially we're talking about
probably four seats so two business
represent representatives and two
Community representatives and as um as I
mentioned to earlier we want to make
sure that we are in we are looking at
organizations that have the skills and
understanding of large-scale sums of
money and how that is managed
um because we understand that it's
that's very different to perhaps
managing a small community organization
or for someone running a small business
and we don't have a huge number of those
kinds of organizations in the district
um so it will probably be quite a small
pool to be looking at so we're just
working through that at the moment
um and working with the leader and as it
says in the cabinet report it will be
for him to approve those those members
because in the original brief to this it
was mentioned I remember as well that
um members of that board where possible
would use their external connections to
enhance the process and all the rest of
it and although they're limited there
are people who've worked behind the
scenes there are other projects and I
think I think some of them have been
discussed Behind these things
they bring a wealth and a connection
that can for example on the Green campus
there's an opportunity to bring in a
large amount of internal investment from
from the private sector
which then fulfills what the leveling up
fund was set out to do but these things
need to be discussed and brought in I
think at this point and therefore should
those that will come through this board
as a steering board or
program
Manning's talking with public and
private sector and and funding
organizations to do that this this board
isn't about changing the project or
necessarily adding to them it's about
are is the funding being spent in the
right way are the budgets being looked
at the delivery time scales the risk it
isn't necessarily about saying oh I can
add value to that because I work in that
sector
that's all happening already from a
project and program management point of
view okay thank you very much
one other
question which I must ask at this point
because the recommendations go through
we're awaiting the start of this
procurement process to identify
operators for the um
for release on the on the ferry side of
things yeah
um without getting into a long rhetoric
there are massive concerns right across
the community about about the delivery
of this in terms of the vessels existing
whilst we're talking about going out and
seeking operators can we perhaps include
some form of
identification and guarantee necessary
of how they would provide this because
the leader this week put a piece out or
last weekend put a piece out in the Isle
of thanet news which has made people's
spines chilled in Ramsgate talking about
another year or two
now we either have people jumping at the
bit to uh to to come here and operate or
we don't there are 185 meter vessels
scrapped in the last three months that
are on the beaches in Turkey there so
whoever is expressing interest I do not
believe have our best interests at heart
in terms of providing a ferry service
and what we don't need to be is an over
spill for other ports
non-desirable Freight or whatever we if
we're going to have a ferry service
let's be honest about it but
we must have an identification of these
vessels because we have a net zero
commitment and if we start bringing in a
lot of old vessels to this port that
then that has Net Zero implications
because of the emissions and exactly the
same as the mountain situation I hope
we've got provision made for those
things to be taken into account before
we go spending money on infrastructure
for something that may not be
deliverable
free
um we are we will be going through a
really robust process because none of us
want to see something fail so
um in terms of the commissioning process
around the concession it will be robust
there are
um questions that relate to the things
that you've just talked about in terms
of potential where the operators might
come from and and contacts that they
have
um and there are there will be questions
in there about our Net Zero commitment
and how how they will work within that
so there it will be a really robust
process
um we are working through all of those
documentation in in order for it to be
able to go out to the marketplace so
that we have everything there up front
for
um potential Port operators because
we're not talking about Ferry operators
directly we're talking about operators
of the port and for them to be able to
use and put together their proposals for
um managing and operating that part of
the port of Ramsgate
um it will be an open and as I said
robust process
and we are using an external legal team
to support us in that who you know are
well connected and have significant
um experience within this sector and of
running similar processes so we are
pretty confident that what we put out
and therefore what we will get back will
be
um really robust in terms of use that
word alive no
um in terms of our ability to manage it
and understand deliverability of their
proposals coming forward ever missed
anything
thank you chair um I don't think you
have missed anything I think I think
it's just worth saying that robust
process with it will include uh several
stages so there's an initial tender
stage uh and then a dialogue stage and
then a final tender stage
um the criteria will include sort of
quality and risk criteria as well as the
financial you know the income criteria
as well
um so yeah the tenders are all written
about around you know the the best value
argument and making sure that those
qualities such as
um health and safety and Net Zero and
those sort of things you know the
commercial viability
um yeah they're sort of Maintenance
requirements and all those sort of
things are are included in their tender
submission
thanks Mike that is encouraging and as I
say I think I want to make it clear that
nobody is trying to be a blocker here or
anything and we would all love a vision
of you know Daiquiris on the deck in the
sunset as we sail out of Ramsgate
there has to be vessel there has to be a
vessel that fits the the geographical
limitations and as I say there's also
the other concerns with the rest of the
infrata report with that channel and how
it relates we've been talking about the
coastline tonight part of the reason the
the north Camp Marine protection Zone
comes round to the pier is specifically
to protect the actual Reef which the
infrared report says that for Ramsgate
to be long-term viable needs to be
widened and deep and well that's not
going to happen with the protections
that are on it so those are the concerns
as to how you can make this thing
configured to fit the vessels that are
viable and in the report it does say be
advised that the recommendations support
the viability of delivery and these are
the concerns as to why it may be that
the business plan looks fine on paper
all very nice ideas but you can't run a
double decker bus out of a Bungalows
garage and that whoever comes along and
says we can operate a port and have the
experience then must have access to the
vessels and there are many who don't
believe those exist so please thank you
thanks Jeff
thank you uh Council Austin
just want to pick up on one thing that
actually follows on from something
cancer Davis said earlier which was
about the level of interest in the
communities about what's happening with
these projects and about how you're
planning on sharing the information
about the changes
and Hereafter how that information will
be shared with the people who are most
affected out there
you talked about events which is
brilliant
um I'm thinking about website and other
kinds of consultation and information
activities
generally I'm hoping that we don't have
many changes because you know we've done
a lot of work in terms of pulling these
projects together
um you know we're not going into this
anticipating that we will have lots of
changes we you know I think we've
probably been through the hardest part
in terms of in increasing costs and and
the inflation so at the moment we're
hoping to manage those and as we talked
at the last meeting some you know value
engineering will have to happen or
looking for other funding at the moment
the biggest changes around the smack
boys
um we if there are changes on specific
projects that include specific
stakeholders we'll be talking to them
anyway and working with them anyway this
isn't about the local Authority making
changes without understanding the impact
of that so you know hopefully they won't
be lots of changes and but we will be
working with all the individual
stakeholders and then through the normal
process of um as I said coming back to
cabinet and we'll have to do engagement
in that way and then
if there is a change and there's funding
become available we will ultimately look
within the different intervention areas
so in Ramsgate you know Harbor or port
or in Margate around Walpole Bay or
um the active movement and connections
we would look within those before we
considered anything else but we also
have to be mindful of the the impact of
inflation so whether some of that be
covered by those rather than starting
brand new projects
the other thing was you talked about
learning between the towns and so on and
I was wondering about within this
project the 10
authorities will there be opportunities
to network and learn from each other
because it seems like a great
opportunity if if there is
I mean I suspect there will be and I
suspect central government will bring us
all together in a room
um it was it you know it's challenging
spending time doing those sorts of
things while we're we're working across
the delivery but we have done that
particularly in the Southeast on Town
deal and now across East Kent we talk a
lot about leveling up so we you know
some of that already exists
it's not a machine gun one very one
point the
partnership board
when is it envisaged that that will
convene and what's the time frame for
launch of it
it's a really good question
um I have our central government at what
point they're going to finalize
everything so it's not particularly an
approval process but they just want to
check and challenge the investment plan
and make sure it's it's
yes yeah so we have to report back in
terms of in the investment plan it says
what our plan is to do and um we will
share the cabinet paper with them so
they can see what our next steps are and
as I said we have a good relation with a
relationship with the department anyway
um we are waiting to hear back but we've
said to them that we do want to set up a
board meeting as soon as we can
obviously we'll need to go through a
process to do that but um yeah I'm
hoping it'll be imminent that we hear
back from them
um thanks Louise that's very useful and
one final question if I could that's got
the sprung into mind
um there was a breakdown of the various
interventions and and aimed outcomes uh
with a budget but where can we find the
breakdown of those budgets
do you mean in the the new pilot yeah in
the report there were the five
intervention areas and there are budgets
they're obviously headline budgets but
where can we find the the breakdown of
how those figures break so we haven't
shared that as as yet
the budgets haven't changed per project
right so all of those
um budgets that we've previously
reported for leveling up town deal
future High Street fund all remain the
same as I said at a project level
everything at the moment Remains the
Same we
um have looked at some reallocation in
terms of the smack boys but we've made
that relatively generic at the moment so
that we can do a bit more work to kind
of Target where that investment goes
um but as it stands those projects
haven't changed in terms of their
budgets it's it's a bit I mean it's not
a helpful process in a way because
they've asked us to map the projects
across the new interventions and then
split out the budget on that basis so if
it's 50 50 on two interventions and it's
a million pounds there's half a million
in each
um so for the purposes of projects the
budget's remainers have been previously
reported but those figures that are
allocated on notional allocations as
opposed to costed figures that are that
are based on a because the projects
obviously aren't developed to the point
where you can have a fully costed it
remains within the funding that has been
allocated for Central from Central
Market so it's an allocated budget
rather than established yeah because we
have to keep within those budgets yeah
okay and when uh will it be item by item
that the business plan on rolls on those
or so so that there is a justification
for how those figures are arrived prior
to
sorry I'm not sure I understand the
question yeah for argument's sake on
let's use fishing let's use the fishing
facilities as an example and I can't
remember I think it was three and a half
million that's like the figure
um
obviously that three and a half million
is an allocation from the from the grant
um but becomes part of a costed budget
in order to deliver the project now
again like the smack boys home we're
well aware that the fisherman's facility
is is let's call it a state of flux at
the moment
excuse me
at what point could we expect to see
though costed breakdown so that instead
of it being a notional budget we've then
got a a an understanding of what that
will cost to deliver because if we don't
get that it's never going to get
delivered
so that will be through the Reba stages
and so we're at Reba stage two moving
into three we are putting together the
packs to commission the last stages and
construction so you will then be able to
see through that process what the final
costs are and where we will have had to
have done value engineering as we
highlighted at the last meeting the
footprint is slightly smaller it doesn't
have a first floor for example but that
means it's within budget so all of that
will come out through those costing
exercises and for the construction
thanks because it's obviously
particularly pertinent at the moment
because with inflation running as it is
and everything else and bill costs
escalating
I'm not sure I'd want to be sitting in
your chairs to be honest so you know
this is critique rather than criticizing
you individually but what I will say is
thank you for your answers we look
forward to further grillings for you but
also well done because when you put all
those funds together there's quite a
substantial chunk that we can make the
difference here with so thank you
chair just on that last question is
there if I had a comment
um so yeah thank you and um so Louise
talked about the Ruby stages which I
think
um you know we'll give Clarity to the
costs
um I think the key Point here is that
this report
um is um is a step in the process and
before we go to procure these works
there's another decision to come
um and I think Louise has already said
that there'll be key decisions because
they're of the value of those decisions
which means they'll be made at cabinet
and they'll come here on their Passage
through to cabinet so you will get to
see more detail about exactly what is
being delivered and exactly what we're
anticipating the cost to be so hopefully
that gives you some insurance
thank you very much Bob much appreciated
and uh well I think I'll speak for quite
a few colleagues as well thank you
yeah another note on next week's meeting
on the forward plan you'll see some key
decisions that are coming forward and
there'll be another extraordinary
meeting in October to discuss those
decisions
Council right
so my question is is probably relates to
to what what Bob she said thank you very
much for your report
um my point here was just how live will
our view of this be
um less about the budget and more about
the red Amber green because what I would
hate to happen is the board gets to you
know this unelected board well unelected
at certain levels gets gets to see
progress regularly
um I don't really want to be waiting for
two or three months before we come back
here and be told that certain I'm sorry
some projects are going to be read at
some stages as you know
um before we get to actually start
asking questions about why things are
happening um so I I think there needs to
be a level of transparency in terms of
the project and how everything's going
um obviously It's tricky because we
don't want to be sharing everything with
the public but from our perspective I
want to be able to know whether I'm
walking I'm going to get report in you
know a couple of weeks time from from
Phil and and the guys
to to bring to our view and scrutiny
when all of a sudden I'm looking at a
lot of red on a page where I Sun I
somehow I'm scrambling around for
details so I'd like a level of
transparency there on how the projects
are actually progressing
thank you as it currently stands we
don't
um share the monitoring and evaluation
reports not for any reason other than if
the decision was taken not to do that
um and also they're terrible
spreadsheets
um but one of the things that we are
looking at doing is streamlining our
internal governance arrangements as well
so within that obviously there there's
the cabinet and overview and scrutiny
process but also an officer level
um from a senior management and then a
project officer so we are streamlining
all of that alongside this and so
there's a really clear flow of
information and Reporting and one of the
things that we're doing around that is
making sure that we have the same
documentation across all of the projects
and programs at the moment they're
slightly different just because of the
way that the two programs particularly
tando and leveling up were set up
um but we are looking at streamlining
that and we can have a headline report
that comes out of those to help feedback
to
um members
um the other thing that we often do is
member briefings so although I'm not on
the next member briefing undoubtedly
there'll be some in the diary to come
and present to members more information
we've done we did quite a big members
briefing on the port before that went
through that cabinet process so that we
articulated what we were doing and what
the next steps would be and then what
the decision making was so there'll be
some more of that coming and we can do a
bit more specific on a project by
project basis but we can we can look at
how we share as you say not everything
needs to necessarily be in the public
domain on a regular basis but we can
look at how we share that information
for for members I think transparency is
absolutely UK it's really important that
we get to see this and you know our job
is also to help you guys as well so
you'll do you know how many times I see
on social media all the council do don't
do X Y and Z and you've got members
popping their heads up and saying well
actually they do and here's what the
council are doing so I think it's really
important that we know as much as
possible as regularly as possible and I
welcome members briefings but
um some of us don't fear a spreadsheet
so that's not going to be an excuse
yeah okay we've got any further
questions
okay so we're asked to review the pilot
report from miseski which I think
councilor Davis has actually done on his
own
so thank you masescue for the report and
we move on to the next agenda item which
is item number nine the publishing of
the TLs annual report and a call on Mr
Sullivan who's managed to wait all this
time to deliver her report thank you
your housing provider we need to produce
an annual report to achieve Regulatory
Compliance it must provide relevant
information that enables tenants to
scrutinize their landlord's performance
this is our second annual report and
it's now ready for publication
as you know we provide quarterly reports
performance reports to OSP and cabinets
and they are also scrutinized by our
involved tenants and leaseholders
this report gives detail on the team's
performance for the year which we have
supported with case studies and photos
we're looking to publish the report on
the council's website we will also
ensure there's plain text version that
can be read by a web reader and the web
page which will include an equality
statement that invites interested
parties to request a printed document or
in other formats
hard copies of the report will be taken
to community events so that anyone
participating can take them away
this report has already been reported
reviewed by the tenant and leaseholder
group and we'll be going to cabinet for
approval to publish on the 21st of
September and looking for any comments
here
thank you thank you Sally I've got
Council attorney who's asked to ask a
question did you get your question
answered in the report or do you want to
I think I'm quite happy with what you've
just said thank you very much
okay thank you Council turning and open
up to members I've got Council of
Brighton Council Austin
just a comment I really enjoyed reading
this
um report I think it's really good work
and thank you for producing it
uh can I Echo that um you know the words
Exemplar and good practice spring to
mind
um most particularly the way that the
team is working with tenants with the
all the various representative groups
but also all the events that you run
I've been to some of them where I
couldn't get to one and sent my
apologies I got documentation the next
day from an officer that sort of
Engagement and things like the we
realized that tenants found our letters
threatening we sat down with tenants and
worked out how to make them less so and
how to to approach that Etc if we did
that across the council I don't mean
that we're threatening across all
aspects of the council but actually
it coms people will have heard me say
this dozens of times because this is my
background
um you know we send stuff out to members
of the public that
is incomprehensible very often it
involves our Council jargon it involves
technical terminology we say we will
endeavor when we could say we will try
you've done that you've you've shown how
it works by working with tenants and
making it accessible and friendly to
tenants and you're building up those
relationships and the the report shows
how how that works you're also reporting
in very clear simple ways against a
whole series of criteria that we can all
understand have you met this have you
nearly met this are you way off and why
that's the kind of reporting I think we
want at this panel and I think that's
the kind of reporting that will help
build up confidence out there in the
community that we are working very hard
and where something isn't working with
with striving very hard to put it right
so brilliant and thank you
cancel the point
thank you yeah completely Echo councilor
Austin has just said it's It's really
informative it's really um easy to
absorb it's engaging it's really lovely
to see the photos before and after
photos are particularly useful so I
think um yeah I just want to
congratulate you really I'd like to see
more reports like that um I have got a
question about the um I don't know what
this is the right form to raise this but
I noticed underneath the um
on the garages
um my kind of question about the garages
is um is there a reason why is it over a
third of the garages are currently
unoccupied
um and if so
um is there a way that we can Market
them a bit better I mean I'm I'm it is
it's to me it seems like missed income
and also an opportunity to get cars off
the roads thank you
um yes uh the the reason they are
unoccupied is because they're not in a
state to be able to be occupied at the
moment and um what we are doing what we
have been doing for the last 18 months
is actually running a program across our
garage Estates to bring them up to a
better standard and then we are
re-letting them we launched recently a
new web page and a form so that
interested parties can digitally get
hold of us and put themselves on a
waiting list we had to close that
waiting list recently because we've got
over 200 applicants for garages so we've
got no shortage of interest it's just
getting the garages up and ready to be
able to be let which we are doing
rapidly
thank you very much
anybody else
okay so we're asked to review uh sell as
you book which clearly we've done and we
thank thank you for coming along this
evening and that's the uh business for
this evening done so we'll see you all
back here next week at the same time